el fuego de la artillería y las miles de
minas sembradas en los campos ucranianos
han disparado el número de mutilados en
Ucrania el técnico nazar bañuke nos
muestra algunas prótesis que se fabrican
en este centro dice que los pacientes
están aumentando y muchos tienen
amputaciones graves
a los soldados se les dan los primeros
auxilios rápidamente les ponen los
torniquetes pero a veces esperan hasta
dos días para ser evacuados
el soldado raso Igor un ex minero se
encontraba en una misión en el área de
gerson en octubre cuando piso un
artefacto explosivo el estallido le
arrancó el pie y parte de su pierna
derecha
nos vamos acercando unos a jerson
ocupamos algunas posiciones enemigas de
los rusos llegamos hasta el río ni pro y
pisé una mina antipersona por eso
lamentablemente no pude llegar a gerson
los amputados de la Guerra de Ucrania se
curan En centros como este donde hay más
de 200 pacientes en listas de espera
muchos mutilados también están
mentalmente exhaustos es lo que se ve en
los ojos de Eugenia trabajaba con
policía y cuando empezó la guerra se
alistó como voluntario dice que está
intentando recuperar su vida pero es muy
duro y lleva meses de terapias
ya no puedo luchar tal vez podré
ocuparme de tareas administrativas pero
no lo sé intentaré recuperar mi vida
será difícil pero lo intentaré
buena parte de los tratamientos y las
prótesis las pagan países extranjeros
Ucrania no tiene recursos suficientes
para cuidar de todos los que se han
dejado sus cuerpos en los campos de
batalla